Summary
Let's recap some of the topics we've covered
in this lecture. We started by talking about
homogeneous coordinates, a different way to
represent points in a 2 dimensional plane.
We talked about ways to convert Cartesian
coordinates to homogeneous coordinates and homogeneous coordinates back to Cartesian
coordinates. Mathematically, lines and points are duals.
This leads to some very nice ways to compute
the intersection points at 2 lines or the
line that is formed by 2 points. We've discussed
a different perspective projection model called
the Central Projection Model and the key difference
is that the image plane is between the object
and the origin and it forms an image that
is not inverted.
We can represent this as a matrix modification
using homogeneous coordinates of the world
point and of the point on the image plane.
In a real digital camera, the image plane
is a large array of light sensitive elements,
which form the pixels of the resulting image.
We need to deal with the discrete nature of
this image plane, the fact that the coordinates
are measured in units of pixels rather than
in units of metres. There's also an origin
shift involved instead of the center of the
image plane, the origin in pixel coordinates
is in the top left corner and we can introduce
that with a simple linear transformation.
Ultimately, we combine a number of matrix
terms together. The first 2 we refer to as
the intrinsic parameters of a camera.
They described the camera entirely in terms
of the dimensions of its pixels, the coordinate
of the principal point and the focal length
of the lens. These are parameters of the camera
itself. It doesn't matter where the camera
is or where it's pointing. The intrinsic parameters
are invariant to the location of the camera.
The 3rd matrix in this chain, we refer to
as the extrinsic parameters and they described
the pose of the camera that is its position
and its orientation with respect to the world's
coordinate frame. We can combine all these
matrices together into a single 3 by 4 matrix
which encodes all that information. So, the
projection from the world point to image plane
point is done simply by a matrix modification
which gives us the homogeneous coordinates
of the point on the image plane and there
is a simple mapping between those homogeneous
coordinates and the Cartesian image plane
coordinates which we typically denote by U and V.
This representation is scale invariant. We can multiply  the camera matrix
by an arbitrary non-zero constant and the projection remains unchanged.
This matrix is often written in a normalized
form where element C34 is equal to 1. If the points lie on a plane in the world, then we
can write a different relationship between
the coordinate of the point on the plane and
the coordinate of the point on the image plane
and we use a 3 by 3 homography matrix to do this
Homography matrix maps points from a plane
to another plane. We can compute the homography
matrix if we know 4 sets of corresponding
points between the 2 planes. Corresponding
means that the point P and the point Q refer
to the same point, the same feature in the
world.
One application of homographies is to compute
perspective rectification. We can compute
an homography H which maps points from point
P in 1 image to point Q in another image and
if we choose H correctly, we can undo the
effect of perspective distortion. Another
application of homographies is that we can
take a rectangular graphic like this and distort
it in such a way that it appears to lay perfectly
into a different plane. In this case, the
plane is the surface of the swimming pool.
The final example of how we might be able
to use an homography is related to the project
part of this course and we can use it to map
a coordinate in the image plane of the camera
to an XY coordinate of a point on the robots
2 dimensional worksheet.